"Укрпошта" відкрила передзамовлення марки "Переможного Нового року!"
з серії, що присвячена відсічі російській агресії.
Офіційно вартість одного аркуша - 88 гривень.
Та чи виросте ціна так само, як у випадку з попередніми "воєнними" марками?
Крайній випуск був присвячений звільненню Херсона
і викликав ажіотажний попит.
Ця марка є особливою, тому що вона була презентована
в день звільнення Херсона Збройними силами України.
Відразу було відкрито передзамовлення на купівлю цієї продукції
і 50 відсотків тиражу було продано за передзамовленням.
Тому на цю марку є ажіотаж по всій Україні.
Номінальна вартість однієї марки "Херсон - це Україна!"
становила 12 гривень, але вже за кілька днів її продавали
значно дорожче, помітили експерти.
Ціна росте одразу, як хтось купує марку і виходить за поріг "Укрпошти".
Щоправда, всі опитані новоспечені власники херсонської марки
категорично заперечували намір її перепродати.
Україну - не продають.
Близьким, родичам подарую.
Стояв довго. П'ять годин. В мене онуки є. Онукам залишу.
Для себе, для пам'яті. А потім, з найпершого тиражу,
як поз'їжджаються всі друзі з-за кордону, всім роздам як пам'ятний сувенір.
Водночас в "Укрпошті" не виключають, що частина покупців
таки має намір заробити на перепродажу марок.
Є ті, хто завжди купує поштові марки України.
Це філателісти, які їх збирають. Є люди, які хочуть залишити
їх на пам'ять своїм дітям, бо поштова марка документує історію,
хроніку подій. А є ті, хто потім хоче перепродати й, можливо,
скерувати ці кошти на допомогу Збройним силам України.
Тим часом ажіотаж навколо українських марок охопив
не тільки Україну, а й поширився на міжнародні майданчики продажів.
Перші марки з російським кораблем, які були продані
на інтернет-аукціоні eBay… Член товариства філателістів
продав там два невеличких аркуші за 6 тисяч доларів.
Хоча наразі в Україні ціни на воєнні марки значно нижчі,
філателіст все ж не радить розглядати їх як інвестицію,
що дасть швидкий прибуток.
Ажіотаж пов'язаний, по-перше, з війною. Ажіотаж почався
з першого "корабля". А особливо підігріло ажіотаж у філателії те,
що корабель пішов туди, куди його послали.
Якщо вам не пощастило купити марки за номіналом від "Укрпошти",
я б не рекомендував зараз купувати їх з рук за шаленими цінами
у сподіванні на здорожчання в майбутньому. Вони не будуть дорожчими.
Але через років 15-20-30 вони дійсно
можуть коштувати набагато дорожче.
Як інвестиції це можна розглядати, але не варто сподіватися,
що ми станемо мільйонерами.
Крім того, в погоні за оригінальною маркою не треба забувати
і про ризик бути ошуканим шахраями. Спалах інтересу до України у світі
призвів до того, що присвячені Україні і її протистоянню
агресору марки мільйонними накладами друкують
навіть африканські країни, що перебувають
в орбіті російського впливу. Так вони поповнюють
свої державні бюджети. Але філателісти нарікають
на велику кількість фальсифікацій таких марок,
які друкують не африканські та азійські поштарі,
а нечисті на руку ділки.
А от українські марки, крім історичної та філателістичної цінності,
мають ще й художню, яка вже визнана
в цілому світі стверджує філателіст.
Протягом останніх 30 років, відколи Україна стала незалежною,
вони відзначалися високою художньою цінністю.
Це підтверджується тим, що протягом останніх 3-4 років
марки "Укрпошти" посідали якщо не перші, то завжди призові місця
на європейських й світових конкурсах.
Цю думку поділяють не тільки філателісти, а й прості українці.
Мені дуже подобалася марка з "Мрією".
Вона, наскільки я знаю, розійшлася не таким широким тиражем,
але мені дуже сподобалася. Я за неї голосувала,
я її купувала, в мене вона є, і мені вона дуже подобається.
До речі, з кавуном мені теж дуже подобається. Ці дві.